e
good morning it being 9:30 I'd like to
call to order the organizational meeting
of the long range Capital planning and
utilization
committee I would like to recogn ize
please motion has been made do we have a
second motion's been made and seconded
all those in favor say I I opposed
motion
carries I would like to make a motion
I'd like to make the motion to nominate
Senator Mark makoni as Vice chair second
motion has been made and seconded we
will not vote on this motion at this
meeting we'll C carry it over to our
next one Senator makoni isn't here to
accept the
nomination I would like to make a
further motion to nominate
representative John cluder as the clerk
of this committee second motion's been
made and seconded and I accept the
nomination Mr chairman thank you sir all
those in favor say I I
carries item number two let's move on to
251 is in your package Mr Shay can you
walk us through this please so just
before that you have the guidelines and
the procedures page so something that
this committee has done for a long
period of time is to um suggest to
agencies what the commission rate should
be if they um have property sold and um
what the final sale can go below 10%
can't go below 10% of what the uh asking
price was that they presented to this
committee um as well as the procedural
aspects of providing information to our
office to get on this agenda and if it's
a late item to ask for the committee's
uh the chair of the committee's
permission to do so um again the
information that you ask related to the
commission and the pricing is more
informational that helps you make the
decision on whether to dispose of
property this committee's charge is to
do an up or down vote on um allowing the
property to be sold or leased um not to
set the the actual dollar to it so if
the committee is okay with that I think
you just would want to get an
affirmative action on that and then the
um item 25-1 is just the statutes that
um you might see as a result of sitting
on this committee when items come
forward and and the organization of the
committee so that's all I got on that
motion to approve approv
motion's been made and seconded all
those in favor say I I opposed motion
carries item three is the acceptance of
minutes of our November 12th
meeting motion has been made and
seconded by Senators Pearl and Lang Mr
chairman I was absent so I will plan I
all those in favor say
I
opposed
abstentions represent cluder
all goodier
fauler motion
25-3 department of administration
Services requests approval on behalf of
the Department of military Affairs and
veteran services to lease from the
Berlin Airport Authority for a term of
up to 55 years and fixed annual rent of
$1 approximately
5.66 Acres of Berlin Regional Airport
land located along the easterly side of
the East Side River Road in the town of
Milan New Hampshire together with any
sight improvements thereon and All
rights of way
AC
accretions I've never seen seen that
before easement
tenements yeah
okay building to be primarily occupied
and used by the New Hampshire Army
National Guard subject to the conditions
as specified in the request dated
20125 you're
up uh good morning Mr chair members of
The Honorable committee my name is Jared
Nyland I'm the real property asset
manager with the New Hampshire
Department of administ ministrative
Services I have General mes here with me
from the Department of military Affairs
and veteran services um this is a
proposed ground lease uh there's about
uh
5.66 acres of land at the burgal Berlin
Regional Airport in milin New Hampshire
um it is adjacent to the to one end of
the runway it is also a buts um what's
the road there East Side River Road in
Island uh currently the the land is
largely undeveloped uh however there are
um I believe there's at least one snile
Trail Crossing it or around it and then
uh I think there's an access point from
the main road um other than that uh the
proposal under the under the ground
lease is for the Department of military
Affairs and veteran services to
construct a uh Army Aviation support
building on site uh this is as I
understand it somewhat similar in con up
to what currently exists at conquered
airport but on a smaller scale
um you have anything to
add good morning Mr Mr chair committee
members um for the record I'm David mtis
the agent general of New Hampshire
National Guard all right so what are we
trying to do um we're trying to build a
hanger to save lives and so in federal
fiscal year 2023 we received
approximately 5.5 million to build a
through a congressionally directed
spending project to build a hanger up in
the Berlin area airport in the town of M
and so it's a very small scale it will
have zero full-time presence and what
it'll allow us to do is to conduct
training in the white modern National
Force and to help ourselves with fishing
games save lives through search and
rescue operations so it's going to be a
no permanent Manning a hanger facility
potentially with a small administrative
section depending on you know how the
construction dollars come out and
there's some PE peculiar things about
this you know one of it is like why a
dollar a year for 50 years the reason
why is there's two reasons one is the
Department of Defense is exempt from FAA
fair market value rates at uh airports
right so you go to the FAA regulation
their compliance rules and you say it's
okay as long as the Department of
Defense has a flying Mission you're
exempt from fair market value the second
thing is when we receive what's called
military construction dollars from uh
the president's budget we have to show
ownership for a minimum of 25 to 30
years so right so you have dollar year
at lease for 50 years and that's the
reason why like I said for the full-time
presence there will be zero full-time
presence there what we're trying to do
is just help our Airmen train our our
our Pilots because next year they're
deploying to Kosovo for United Nations
peacekeeping Mission so every 3 to four
years our helicopter units deploy and
because of the size of the training area
in the white modern National Forest
having a pre-positioned hanger that's
available in the event a helicopter
breaks in the event we have to Stage
something up there for search and rescue
operations
it just increases the value and
opportunity for us to train our soldiers
and
Airmen any questions comments Senator
Lang move to approve I'll second motion
has been made and
seconded all those in favor say I I
carries if I may Mr chair um I did want
to add one thing to the record when we
when we submitted this item uh the the
maximum lease term was 55 years uh on
Friday we learned that the Federal
Aviation Administration objects to any
lease longer than 50 years at this
airport so we have revised that so it's
now 50 years is the maximum lease term
not
Shay I think we're fine it's on the
record okay thank you very much as long
as the committee's okay with that
Justice requests approval of a 30-year
lease with conquered hospital for a
10,500 squ ft space at 279 Pleasant
Street in conquered New Hampshire as
premises for the chief medical examiner
offices morg and OCT tosy Suite which
would also include the services of two
full-time medical examiner
assistants
and. 25 man security with a lease
effective date planned for March 1st
2026 with an end date of February 28th
m259
882 over the release term subject to the
conditions as specified in the requests
2025 welcome to capital budget
overview morning Mr chairman members my
name is Sean Gil I'm the chief of staff
at the Department of Justice and I'm
here with our chief medical examiner Dr
Jenny Duval the medical examiner's
office is a component of the Department
of Justice which is why we're here
together today we're here to ask the
committee's approval to proceed with the
lease for premises at 279 Pleasant
Street for the medical examiner's office
autopsy suite and
morg the chief medical examiner is
required by law to conduct death
investigations in 24 different
categories of deaths many of those
involve
autopsies this year alone they're on
course to uh conduct about 750 autopsies
the state doesn't own any building or
facilities that are capable of
conducting autopsies or storing bodies
pending autopsies so for the past 39
years plus minus we've been leasing
office space from conquered hospital at
250 Pleasant Street the um Office Park
adjacent to the main hospital and then
paying a separate fee for every time
that the medical examiner uses the morg
to conduct an
autopsy that lease and that Arrangement
are due to expire next year and the
hospital's made clear that we're not
going to be able to continue on the same
terms that we've had in years past
they'd like to make other uses for the
offices that the medical examiner
currently
occupies um for for their own purposes
and the morg that the medical examiners
using that they're sharing with the
hospital is getting to be inadequate
over the year with the number of cases
they do going up with the addition of a
third medical examiner with their body
storage at capacity in fact Dr dval can
talk about uh some uh present day
examples of that but they're exceeding
the capacity to store bodies there at
the hospital and the more in the
basement of hospital is a footprint that
can't be expanded so we've had
conversations with the hospital they've
identified another location just up the
road at 279 Pleasant Street and they're
willing to build out and fit out the
first floor of that building to
accommodate the medical examiner offices
an autopsy suite for three doctors and
body storage morg for basically double
the capacity that the medical examiners
have now so we're asking the committee's
permission to proceed with the lease
along the terms that were laid out in a
letter of intent the party signed at the
end of last year and it would be over a
term of 30 years the hospital would
build out as I say and equip the
facility for the exclusive use of the
medical examiner for its offices morg
and autopsy Suites so we're available to
answer any questions the committee might
have
any questions or comments Senator Lang
move to approve
25004 motion has been made and seconded
any questions or comments seeing none
all those in favor say I I
opposed motion carries thank you thank
you Mr chair me yes
sir I move the chairs allowed to just
reference the item number in the
department we all have that agenda in
front of us we can read it to save you
from the long dissertation that you have
to go through on each one of these
you moving on to the Department of
Safety lrcp
25012 requests authorization to enter
into a lease agreement with the city of
conquer at 91 Airport Road for a period
please welcome welcome to Capital
project state your name good morning Mr
chairman members of the committee I'm
Amy Newbury I'm the director of
administration with the Department of
Safety and um item 25 012 authorizes the
department of safety the division of
State Police to enter into a lease
agreement with the city of conquer um
for the premise of 91 Airport Road um
it's a 10 lease agreement with the
option to renew for two one-year periods
um the lease has a 3% escalation each
year the property currently houses the
New Hampshire State Police aircraft and
it's home to the mobile enforcement
team the land is
2,350 ft and on that land is the hanger
the airport hanger and that is $8,500
and 60 square ft um The Hanger obviously
is the aircraft storage but also has
some office space and we're really
excited to enter into the potential of
12 Years lease because that hanger is
currently undergoing a complete
capital and I'm happy to answer your
questions any questions move to approve
item
2512 Senator Lang moves approving and
and seconded by Senator
Pearl questions or comments seeing none
all those in favor say I I
carries moving on to lrcp 25-5
Department of
Transportation requests approval to
continue efforts to dispose of two
Parcels of State own land located at 105
South Main Street and Sexton Avenue in
conquer you're up Sir identify yourself
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Eric Sergeant
administrative Bureau rway Department of
Transportation
res to RSA 4 colon 39c the department
requests approval to continue efforts to
dispose of two contiguous Parcels of
state-owned land consist of 67 Acres
located at 105 South Main Street in seon
Avenue in conquer these Parcels are
Remnant uh remnants of larger Parcels
that were required for the construction
of store Street Extension the parcels
are regular shaped with limited access
parcel a was acquired from Maran Shepard
in 1981 for
$211,000 for the total area of 309 Acres
of which. 26 Acres remain that was not
needed for rway purposes is identified
as conquered tax map 28 lot 14 parcel B
was acquired from Elbert and Lorraine
manui in 1981 for $62,000 with a total
area of 0489 Acres The Remnant piece
being 041
Acres uh parcel B is conquered tax map
28 lot
13 the department originally received
approval by committee dispose of these
Parcels on September 15 2023 lcrp item
2325 with a listing price of $1,100,000
parcels have been active for sale on the
open market on multiple listings since
September
2023 departments received feedback from
potential buyers the listing price of
$1,100,000 is not financially viable in
the current marketing conditions
contributing factors are current
inflation and and increased interest
rates
the Realtors received limited interest
in the parcels at the current market
price the listing agent also
acknowledged that the original listing
price was inflated due to past market
conditions the listing firm of the Prof
is of the professional opinion that the
price reduction is
warranted Department's recent appraisal
of December 2024 done by licensed
certified General appraiser provided the
market value of $875,000
in consider ation of this information
and with the committee's approval
department will retroactively extend the
listing agreement for a term of one year
with nii Norwood group for the period of
November 20th 2024 to November
2025 November 20th 2025 with a listing
price of 875,000 the department will
also assess administrat fee of
$100 uh conditions of the sale would
include the buyer to commission a land
surveyor licens in New Hampshire prepare
boundary survey uh depicting the
existing RightWay the buyer shall be
responsible for all local and state land
use approvals before the
closing due to the proximity of the
conquered uh of the property the
conquered municipal airport before any
proposed construction or alteration of
structures of temporary equipment used
on this property the proponent will need
to notice the
FAA uh parcel B is encumbered by 20
foot5 uh 25t wide permanent sewer
easement and an 8 in drain line uh the
con St will contain language for
accepting reserving these easements for
have any questions move to approve item
number
25005 motion has been made and seconded
by representative cluder any questions
or comments I do have one
comment Senator l so having been on this
committee when we put this land on the
listing to begin with last term I
believe it was as a do we have any
expectation we'll actually sell it with
the slope of that land and the access of
that land being guard railed from store
street thank you for the question
Senator that is a it is a limiting
factor the the topography and the uh
access is not ideal but there is some
interest that the realtor feels that A
reduced price that should generate more
interest thank you rob
fauler my question is related the only
access to this property is by seon
Street not not from stores is that
correct thank you for the question yes
yes representative the uh it is only by
sex and have no no access from store
Street would be
provided any other questions comments
saying none all those in favor say I I I
carries moving on to
lrcp 2
5-
006 carry on sir thank you Mr chairman
Department requests authorization to
sell six Parcels of land consisting of
9.49 acres of state-owned land uh along
New Hampshire Route 16 and US Route 302
in Conway the department will enter into
a listing agreement for one term a
oneyear term with Pinkham real estate
the subject property will include all
six Parcels with a listing price of
$1,800,000 with an administrative fee of
$1,100 pink and real estate if
successful in this sale will be given a
4% sales
commission Department originally
received approval by the committee on
April 12 2024 as L CRP item
2415 at that time New Hampshire Housing
Finance Authority was the buyer the sale
the sale terminated at the request of
New Hampshire housing upon further
review of the parcels Department
determined excuse me upon further review
of the parcels Department determined the
original requested acreage of 7.2 Acres
was incorrect and has since revised and
949 uh the six Parcels were acquired
part of the Conway bypass project which
was later dissolved in
2020 C 304 was acquired in 2002 from
Arthur Roberts and Mary Su withough for
323,000 and is currently identified as
part of tax map 215 lot 58 r 305 was
acquired
98 from Ruth buris uh for
178,000 parcel 305 is currently is part
of the current tax map 2115 lot
108 parel 307 was acquired in 1999
Frederick AB bruy for 150,000 parcel 307
is part of current tax map 250 in lot
108 parcel 38 was acquired in ' 04 from
inisi for $5,200 parcel 3 308 is part of
current tax map 2115 lot
57 parel 309 and 310 were acquired in
1996 from Gan Channel realy Inc for
$122,000 parcel 309 is part of current
tax map con tax map 2115 lot 108 and
parcel 310 is part of the current tax
map 2115 Lot
56 conditions of the sale include the
buyer commissioning a licensed land
surveyor to prepare a Min survey
illustrating the existing RightWay or
any mutually agreed Pond
adjustments controlled AIS of the
RightWay will be set along route 16302
to be consistent with the existing
controlled access RightWay in this area
the subject property shall be limited to
no more than two points of
access the buo will be responsible for
local and land local and state land use
approvals before closing uh accepting
and reserving a 30 foot access point for
the proc identified as Conway tax map 25
lot 60 as shown on Conway 11339 I
construction plans uh also accepting and
reserving all slope and drainage
easements as shown on the Conway 11339 I
construction
plans accepting and reserving two
utility easements on parel
310 a staff appraiser from the
Department evaluated the property and
concluded it does have independent
highest best use as a single parcel
single economic unit as an investment
opportunity for high commercial Andor
High density development with a
determined fair market value of
$1,666 th000 $660,000
the department received a market
analysis from three different realtors
and we determined that pink and real
estate based on their market analysis
estimated value was closest to the state
appraisal which was done by licensed
survey General praiser therefore it will
be it was determined Pinkham real estate
was the successful bidder pursuant to
RSA 439c
Department solicited interest from the
town of Conway who subsequently declined
interest pursuing to RSA 204 D colon 2
Department solicit interest from New
Hampshire Housing Finance Authority and
they are no longer interested in
purchasing purchasing the uh identified
Parcels that's all I have any
questions seeing none motion's been made
by Senator Pearl I'll second that motion
seconded by representative
cluder
questions saying none all those in favor
say I I opposed motion
carries continuing with the do
lrcp
25-7 request
to dispose of seven Parcels of state
owned land continue sir thank you Mr
chairman Department request approval
disposed of seven Parcels of state owned
land in Lisbon four Parcels are located
on the eastly side of hodg Hill Road and
the remaining three Parcels are located
on the westle side with total acreage of
3.83
Acres the department will enter into a
listing agreement for a one-year term
with Badger pey and Smith
realy the seven Parcels of land were
acquired for the Troy bypass project was
later dissolved in August 2016 and are
identified as follows tax map use 7 lot
22 is4 Acres U7 23 at84 Acres U7 24 at
049 Acres u725 at 0.5 Acres
u57 uh excuse me U7 lot 57 at47 Acres U7
lot 58 at 509 acres and lot tax map U7
lot 59 at 62
acres the three Lisbon tax Lots
identified as U 757 U7 58 and U7 59
located on the Wesley side HUD Hill
would be marketed as a combined sale at
$88,500
u722j with the two combined cluster
listings the listing price breakdown for
each lot would be the following
u7c U 722 32,000 U 723 at
39,000 U7 24 at 30,000 u725 at
32,000 U7 57 34,000 U7 58 34,000 and U7
59 at
36,000 market analysis is found listing
all as listing as individual lots and
combining clusters will likely attract
buy buyers seeking either smaller
marketable procs for personal use or
investment and buyers also seeking to
take advantage of lower price per acre
in the cluster listings which allows for
more affordable investment overall
combining multiple Lots also provides
more land area for development increased
value in
resale the department will assess
administrative fee of $1,100 pursuant to
RSA 4 colon
43a badger bu and Smith real estate if
successful in these sales will be given
a 6% sales
commission the process will be sold as
is where is with no additional
conditions the buyer will be responsible
for obtaining all local and state
approvals before closing pre-qualified
realtors in this region were sent to a
request to submit a market analysis for
the subject properties based on this
request Department received one response
from Bader p and
Smith the values provided in this
analysis aligned with the state's
appraisal done in July of 2024 which was
done by a licensed certified General
appraiser department will solicit the
interest from the town of lisman pursu
to RSA 4 col 39 C and will interest New
Hampshire Housing Finance Authority
2 questions regarding this
matter Senator Pearl so just quickly
looking through this thanks for coming
in today by the way there at least one
of these lots that is not doesn't appear
like it's large enough to build so
you're looking to list the Lots
individually and then as a group cluster
or is there any thought towards selling
maybe combining a couple of them to make
them if they're substandard to make them
large enough to build
on thank you for the question Senator
yes that is all possibilities were
looked at and based on the realtor's
professional opinion we've come up with
this solution thinking this would get
attract the most buyers individually
again for the houses that are are meat
zoning can be developed and then as the
Clusters to combine those to for more
affordable uh development
purposes move to approve motion's been
made to approve I'll second that and
seconded by representative cluder any
other questions seeing none all those in
carries moving on continuing with the
Department of s of Transportation
lrcp
25-8 requests the authorization to sell
approximately 1 and a half acres of
state-owned land on the Northerly side
of Route 25 and rest of and west of
Route 153 in the town of
Effingham thank you Mr chairman
Department requests authorization to
sell approximately 1.5 Acres of State
own land located on the northly side of
New Hampshire Route 25 and west of New
Hampshire Route 153 in Effingham the
sale will be direct to the butter James
Owen in the amount of
22,000 plus an administrative fee of
$1,100 the parel of lamb was acquired as
part of the larger parcel from Sylvia
brenick in 1987 for the construction and
realignment of Route 25 in
Effingham conditions of the sale include
the buyer commissioning a land survey
license in New Hampshire to prepared
boundary
survey illustrating the existing Redway
and any Mutual agreed upon
adjustments the buyer will be
responsible for all local and state
approvals before closing no access shall
be granted to New Hampshire 25 access to
the pass will be via Route
153 a staff appraiser from the
Department evaluated the property based
on its contributory value which was
determined to be $22,000 per statute per
state statute the town of Effingham New
Hampshire Housing Finance
Authority will be first offered the
questions motion has been made and
seconded by Senators Pearl and Lang a
further question yes
representative as I look at the map
you're proposing not to sell this entire
arsal but cutting
off the um northern little triangle is
that is that correct is that going
somewhere
else uh the it was requested or
determined that that parcel is is uh
being uh offers some enjoyment to the
budding parcel uh to the east of it I
believe and therefore the it was not
necessary for this part of the sale that
part was not necessary for this sale the
butter uh that requesting this Mr Owens
is is located Westerly and easterly of
right so it's been retained there's no
proposal to do anything with that little
triangle at the present time I'm sorry
could the proposal is to retain that
little triangle not to not to dispose of
it at the present
time I believe that is the case yes
sorry thank
you any other questions saying none all
those in favor say I I
lrcp
25-9
do requests authorization to sell 0.15
Acres of State oat land located on the
northwesterly side of New Hampshire
Route 13 in the town of Mount
Vernon thank you Mr chairman Department
requests authorization to sell
approximately 0.15 acres of state-owned
land located on the northwesty side of
Hampshire Route 13 in Mount Vernon the
property is not recognized by the town
of Mount Vernon as an independent lot of
record rather it is a portion of the
former Route 13 which was discontinued
by the town of Mount Vernon the sale
will be cont uh direct to the butter of
Frank on hous in the amount of N9 excuse
me
$9,800 plus an administrative fee of
$1,100 parel of land was acquired as
part of a large parel from George blood
and George Carlon 1952 for the
construction and realignment of nire
Route 13 in Mount Vernon conditions of
the sale include the buyer commissioning
a land surveyor license in Hampshire
perimeter boundary surveying
illustrating
the the existing r or any mutually
agreed upon adjustments the buyer will
be responsible for obtaining all local
and state approvals before closing staff
appraiser from the Department evaluate
the property based on its contributive
contributory value which was determined
to be
$9,800 per state statute the town of
Mount Veron New Hampshire Housing
Finance Authority will be offered the
property
first any
questions approve
29 second motion has been made and
seconded questions concerns seeing none
all those in favor say I I
opposed motion
carries I believe we're at the end of
the Department of Transportation thank
moving on to disposal of real estate
lrcp
25-10 department of administrative
Services requests approval on behalf of
the New Hampshire Department of military
fair and of veteran services to sell on
behalf of the state of New Hampshire to
Hillsboro welcome to long range Capital
planning sir you're up again good
morning again Mr chairman members of The
Honorable committee um this uh proposed
disposal uh consists of two easements um
both relatively small one is a temporary
construction easement along the existing
um I think it's a Route 11 RightWay uh
in
Hillsboro um and then the other one and
this is a temporary construction just a
strip of land basically allowing uh
access to um the project which is a
sidewalk project uh and being conducted
by the town of Hillsboro as I understand
it in partnership with
do
um that is the temporary okay so there a
temporary construction eement which is a
small strip of land along the right of
way and then there is a Perpetual uh
drainage infrastructure easement a
little further also on the Frontage with
the right away near the corner a lot and
that is for a uh a culvert and drain and
uh I think some other uh roadway
drainage infrastructure
um the total area affected is um just
over a th000 square feet for the
temporary construction easement which
would have a a expiration term of two
years uh maximum expiration term of two
years and then the Perpetual uh drainage
infrastructure ement is even smaller 4
67 sare ft proposed area any
questions to approve item number
2510 motion has been made and
seconded by
Senators Lang and
pearl I see he he does that
sometimes any further questions or
concerns seeing none all those in favor
say I I
opposed motion
25-1 Department of administrative
Services Bureau of Court facilities to
enter into a use of premises agreement
with the county of
Rockingham welcome to long range Capital
planning sir thank you Mr chairman
excuse me and the members of the
committee I'm Brian Young assistant
administrator with the bureau Corp
facilities uh we work under Department
of administrative Services the
department wishes to continue to lease
out 1853 Square ft of state-owned space
on the lower level of the Rockingham
County Superior Courthouse located at 10
Route 125 and Brentwood for the
Rockingham County's use of office space
for County attorney and deeds Department
the agreements for the period of May 1
2025 to December 31st 2025 for a total
revenue of $129,000
552 oh 129 excuse me
$552 72 the space being utilized by the
county is a benefit to both the state
and the county for the functionality and
efficiency of the Court the state does
recuperate its costs through this
agreement for the space thank
you any
questions move to approve item
2511 I'll second that Mo motion has been
made and
seconded questions or concerns seeing
none all those in favor say I I
opposed motion carries thank you thank
you
sir miscellaneous items moving on we
have none informational items we have a
number of them um would you please walk
us through these Mr Shay lrcp
25-2 so um 002 is the b b anual report
that this committee looked at in draft
form in November this was from our
office this basically is all the actions
the committee took in 23 and
24 um related to um selling of
properties or leasing properties and so
it just compiles all that information
and gives you a status update um through
November the next three items are from
the Council on resources and development
so projects that want to be disposed of
have to go to that committee to get
their approval as well and these are
just um their minutes telling that they
projects no actions are needed on any of
this thank you sir then the next thing
we have to do is set the date of our
next meeting I believe we tentatively
have April
Monday seeing no
it
Senator Senator
Pearl all those in favor say I I post We
Stand adjourned okay thank you Mr